so on thursday night leftists across the
country
were stricken by grief mourning the
death of a man named bernard
brandon bernard he was as is so often
the case with
those the left choose to mourn a
convicted criminal
one of five federal executions scheduled
to be carried out between this week and
inauguration
if all of these executions are performed
it will make 13 total since july and
donald trump will be
as the bbc has labeled him the quote
most prolific execution president in
more than a century
the huffington post was slightly less
reserved accusing trump of going on an
end of office killing spree now it
remains to be seen whether all of these
executions in the coming weeks
will provoke the same level of
performative outrage and sorrow
in bernard's case if you happen to check
twitter on the night of his lethal
injection
you might be forgiven for thinking that
a nobel winning human rights champion or
war hero had met his demise kim
kardashian
especially broken up about it all called
bernard amazing
hopeful positive and quote selfless as
always
as always elsewhere we were urged to
say his name and remember his name to
mark down the day of his death and
remember it as a historical outrage and
atrocity
many news outlets published articles
decrying the execution
now if you're wondering what brandon
bernard actually did to earn this
punishment you'll have to read quite far
down into these articles to find the
crime described in any great detail
if it's described at all but here's an
account
of bernard's crime from the doj website
here's what they say
says brandon bernard and his accomplices
brutally murdered two youth ministers
todd and stacy bagley
on a military reservation in 1999.
after todd bagley agreed to give a ride
to several bernard's accomplices
they pointed a gun at him forced him and
stacy into the trunk of their car
and drove the couple around for hours
while attempting to steal their money in
pawn stacey's wedding ring
while locked in the trunk the couple
spoke with their abductors about god
pleaded for their lives
the abductors eventually parked on the
fort hood military reservation where
bernard and another accomplice
doused the car with lighter fluid as the
couple still locked in the trunk
sang and prayed after stacy said jesus
loves you
and jesus take care of us one of the
accomplices shot
both todd and stacey in the head killing
todd and knocking stacey unconscious
bernard then lit the car on fire killing
stacy through smoke inhalation
now bernard's many defenders cried that
he made a mistake
did a bad thing quote made poor choices
to use kim kardashian's phrasing
but you know we shouldn't execute him
now because of it they say
yes but kidnapping two people driving
them around in the trunk of their car
while they beg for their lives
then murdering them in cold blood and
burning their bodies
is not merely a poor choice it is vile
unspeakable unthinkable shocking
evil it's the kind of choice that once
you make it
you have forfeited your right to live in
a civilized society
in our country you know we don't execute
people for stealing a loaf of bread
or voicing an offensive opinion or
criticizing the government
we don't even execute people for much
more serious crimes like sexual assault
and child abuse
in order to earn the death penalty you
have to really
earn it you must act with a level of
cruelty and depravity
and indifference that just sends shivers
down the spine of any person with a
conscience
brandon bernard acted in that way and
received the punishment he deserved
because of it
now speaking of depraved indifference
and cruelty the next person in line for
a federal execution set to be carried
out
uh today i believe in fact is alfred
burjo
now already some on the left are
rallying to his defense
burjo was convicted in 2002 of killing
his two-year-old daughter
he beat her to death by bashing her head
against the windshield
and dashboard of his truck this was his
final act
of savagery towards the child who he had
already molested and tortured
whifter burned her the others on deck
are lisa montgomery
strangled a pregnant woman to death cut
her open and kidnapped her baby
corey johnson convicted of murdering
seven people
and dustin john higgs found guilty in
the murder and kidnapping of three women
now surveying this collection
of bloodthirsty monsters i find no
reason to shed
any tears except for their victims whose
stories are not told and whose names are
not put on the poster boards
or made into hashtags but with that said
you know i don't
i don't begrudge those who take a
principled and consistent stand against
the death penalty in all cases
i used to hold that view myself it's not
unreasonable to argue
that the government simply shouldn't
execute anybody no matter how monstrous
they may be
um i've come to find that argument
flawed but it's it's a it's a it's a
perfectly valid and
cogent argument all the same the problem
is that a great many of the people
rushing to defend men like brandon
bernard and alfred burjo
are not making valid and cogent
arguments
the anti-death penalty argument is
primarily advanced
by those who do not have the
intellectual or moral credibility to
defend it
their answer to the question who do we
have the right to kill
is so impossibly deranged that you
wonder how a person can hold such a view
and still manage to sleep at night or
look themselves in the mirror
so let's never forget that when someone
on the left
speaks out against capital punishment
insisting as alexandria casa cortez and
iana presley did last night
that we abolish the death penalty they
do not
actually want to abolish the death
penalty in all cases rather
they wish to abolish the death penalty
for convicted criminals
while still giving the death penalty to
children
the pro-abortion anti-death penalty
position suggests
that a man who tortures and rapes a
toddler before crushing her skull
against the windshield of his car
has the right to live but a child in the
womb
doesn't greater moral standing
is given to the mass murderers and child
killers than unborn infants much greater
because the infant has absolutely no
moral standing at all
by this way of thinking i mean remember
that
the pro-abortion people they believe
that the child in the womb
has zero moral standing none
uh i can understand the argument
that both the baby and the criminal have
the right to life i don't agree with it
but it's coherent
okay i can even understand the
nihilistic argument that neither have
the right to life
nobody has a right to life again i
certainly don't agree with that but
it's coherent but the argument that only
the criminal has the right to life and
the child has
no right to life is completely
incoherent morally and intellectually
it doesn't even rise to the level of
nihilism it's something even more
debased
and a whole lot more confused
but the irony is that the people who
advocate for executing children
but not child killers will often make
the hypocrisy charge against those who
take the opposite view
we hear this over and over again we
heard it a lot last night they insist
that somehow it's inconsistent and
convoluted to be anti-abortion and
pro-death penalty
but there is nothing illogical or
strange about this position at all
i mean even some pro-lifers we'll say
we'll we'll make this same case
there's some somehow there's there's an
inconsistency here
no we who hold this position believe
that it is always wrong to intentionally
kill
a defenseless and innocent person
those are the three qualifiers
intentionally kill defenseless
innocent we do not believe
that it is always wrong to kill anyone
at all under any circumstance
almost nobody believes that save quakers
and the rare libertarian who actually
takes his rhetoric to its logical
conclusion
everybody else accepts that sometimes
it's okay to kill a person
now we who hold this view suggest that
sometimes includes self-defense
war and executing convicted murderers
the left would say that sometimes means
perhaps self-defense in war and also
babies in the womb
that's their position that is the
inconsistent position
that is what makes no sense whatsoever
no moral sense anyway
so this is not ground that we can see to
them and and and pretend that there's
some sort of inconsistency
in being pro-life and pro-death penalty
i'll say it again one more time just
just to be very clear about this
our position is that it's wrong to
execute babies
but that doesn't mean it's wrong to
execute a man who for example
beats his two-year-old daughter to death
against the windshield
that's the position their position
is utterly deranged completely
incoherent
and we should remember that especially
in the days ahead when they are
lamenting uh these executions
carried out against people who
absolutely deserved it deserve it
and have earned it and it's as simple as
that hey you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated